قال محمد جمشيدي المساعد السياسي لمكتب
الرئيس الايراني ان المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافائيل جروسي عبر
خلال لقائه رئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
عن رضاه للتوصل الى جدول اعمال مشترك بين
الوكاله الدوليه وهيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه من اجل اتخاذ اجراءات تمهد
الطريقه للتعاون واضاف في تغريده على
تويتر ان رئيسي اعتبرت التعاون مساله
ثنائيه يمكن ان تستمر على اساس الحفاظ على
استقلاليه الوكاله وحقوق الشعب الايراني
حسب تعبيره
هذا واورد مراسل الجزيره نقلا عن الرئاسه
الايرانيه ان الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم
رئيسي ابلغ مدير الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه رافائي ان رد ايران اراده قويه
وحسنانيه للتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه كما قال الرئيسي ان طهران
تعمل من وكاله الطاقه الذريه التعامل
بمهنيه وعدم التاثر بقوى سياسيه تسعى
لاهداف خاصه مشيرا الى ان امريكا والكيان
الصهيوني يستغلان ملف ايرانا نووي ذريعه
لممارسه الضغوط على الشعب الايراني حسب
تعبيرهم